[Musique]
jean françois nativel je suis élu
départemental pour le dix neuvième
canton je suis enseignant et j'ai 49 ans
c'est un canton très diversifié avec une
zone débat bien développé et léo qui
reste encore à aménager
vous y êtes attachés alors bien
évidemment j'y suis attaché même si je
suis plutôt de saint paul ville de la
baie de saint paul mais ça fait
plusieurs années que je vis sur le dix
neuvième canton et je me suis aussi
beaucoup battu pour préserver l'accès à
la mer dans le cadre des attaques de
requins et donc c'est là où j'ai mon
plus fort ancrage
alors les actions prioritaires que je
souhaite mener ce serait par exemple de
pouvoir aider à la rénovation de la
caserne de la saline les bains en y
associant une brigade nautique de
pompiers parce que c'est une zone où les
activités se sont beaucoup développées
les activités nautiques ou encore porter
des projets
d'accompagnement du sens moral et
civique chez les collégiens parce qu'il
ya en tant qu'enseignant je constate de
gros déficits à ce niveau là et puis
bien sûr tous les projets qui rentre
dans le cadre des compétences d'un
conseiller départemental
les compétences c'est le com jeudi le
bras de levier de l'action sociale et à
l'île de la réunion avec la moitié de la
population qui vit en dessous du seuil
de pauvreté le rôle du département est
fondamentale et j'espère qu'avec cette
mandature on va pouvoir contribuer à un
meilleur une meilleure situation sociale
et un meilleur bien-être de l'ensemble
de la population de l'île de la réunion